technology has long been an athlete's
secret weapon
searching for the slightest competitive
edge the best players across sports are
willing guinea pigs and companies from
the fortune 500 to silicon valley
startups know it tens of billions of
dollars are spent every year on
everything from the newest shoe to
wearables to big data driven apps but
one of the biggest technologies to
emerge in sports over the last decade is
aimed at doing something you don't
traditionally see in the classic
training montage
recovery technology aims at helping
athletes bounce back from the intense
training and activity their bodies go
through and make the most of those high
octane workouts you do not get stronger
that moment that you're lifting the
barbell you get stronger as your body is
making repairs making recovery recovery
is a win and how you get fitter faster
stronger
recovery technology includes everything
from massage guns and foam rollers to
compression boots hyperbaric chambers
cryo chambers
infrared saunas and even infrared
pajamas
and athletes are partnering to become
investors to take those products
mainstream
when you look at tech and sports right
now it's completely innovating the way
training's going completely changing the
way recovery is going i think sky's the
limit as far as where it can go but
while some of these products can feel
amazing it can be difficult to
differentiate between what really helps
the body and what just tricks the mind
so many of these things end up not
holding up every time you're chasing the
latest greatest newest tool you're
probably chasing a mirage
so i'm a former d1 athlete myself and
nearly a decade ago recovery looked a
lot different than it does now we made
sure to recover from injuries but for
professional athletes who have made it
their job to keep their bodies operating
at peak performance even into their late
30s and sometimes 40s recovery is touted
as one of the most important tools to
both prevent injury and elongate their
careers i feel like it makes me you'll
feel better it makes me helps me recover
fast so this is an opportunity for me to
take care of my body no pain no gain
recovery has also been a big source of
business for athletes while many
athletes have appeared in marketing for
various products
many are also making direct investments
into them as well
including all pro running back christian
mccaffrey who not only uses products
created by company hyperice but he
became an investor in the business
itself when i first started talking with
everyone from hyperice i had actually
been a fan of the product myself for a
long time i think the biggest thing you
get when
you're dealing with recovery and the
biggest thing that athletes want is
convenience
obviously having suffered a few injuries
these last two years it has been very
tough and and having products like hype
rice have been huge for me not just
being able to recover and come back
quickly but also in training in general
and just staying at the top of my game
at all times
christian and other athletes have
pointed to the convenience factor of
these products giving them the ability
to work on their own bodies outside of a
training room the amount of recovery
that you can do is limitless you don't
have to be in the training room 24 7 to
be able to recover you can kind of take
ownership of that at your house as well
not just sit there in soreness and say
well hopefully i feel good tomorrow now
i can do something about it now because
i have something in the palm of my hand
in 2020 the nfl made hype rice their
official recovery technology partner
following investments from athletes like
patrick mahomes j.j watt jarvis landry
and mccaffrey
players have been investing more and
more in other technology as well
some with clearly questionable
scientific support
tom brady's sleep pajamas for example
rely on infrared technology that they
claim helps promote better sleep
but not only is this not approved by the
fda the best studies for such technology
come from experiments with rats
still recovery's importance for athletes
has led it to become a big business
hyperice is one of few major brands that
have taken recovery tools used by
professional trainers and elite athletes
and marketed them for everyone
hyperice has partnered with some of the
largest sports brands and is estimated
to be valued around 1 billion dollars
one of their biggest competitors in the
space is therabody the company that
created the original there gun which was
made by this guy
jason warsland
in 2007 i was in a motorcycle accident
as a chiropractor i knew the things that
i needed and most of them were in my
office in my practice and i can't bend
bundle them up and take them with me so
i just went to my garage and i grabbed
some tools and brought them in and i
started messing around with them and i
just made something
i started using it on myself and
when i tell people that it worked
meaning the pain stayed away
for minutes 20 minutes at a time as long
as i had it on my body i could tolerate
the pain
to say the least that first prototype
was not a consumer-facing device but the
principal idea what's known as
percussive therapy was there from the
beginning percussive therapy as a
concept has been around for centuries
you can see it in a swedish massage
technique known as tapotement
where hands and fingers are used to
rhythmically drum on the body
here in the 1920s you can see a similar
percussive therapy device
this stuff's been around since the
40s and 50s
i mean they used to take a like a
blender sort of design that had an up
and down motion to it and the doctors
would use that on patient
horseland would begin to tweak his
original design and started to use his
device on other patients facing similar
pain
he contends that three factors in the
design of the theragun were key
the amplitude or the depth the massage
ball would move up and down
the frequency the number of times per
second it could move up and down and the
torque or stall force how much pressure
you could apply before the motor would
stall
the result their body claims will
increase blood flow and relieve tension
and pain temporarily in the treated area
something that worsely initially found
useful in treating patients in pain
[Music]
so how did it go from like kind of
working on injuries to
i want to do this almost you know every
day to stay healthy yeah yeah so i would
actually treat athletes celebrities and
they would take my product when i wasn't
there and they would take it out on the
gym floor i would get so mad at them and
i asked one of them
what are you doing and he said oh dude
this makes my i don't get sore and so as
he's telling me this i'm thinking
holy crap i didn't even realize that
their body would launch their first
product in 2016 but that was before any
scientific research could be done on the
product
the theragun got out way before we could
do studies that was a tough thing for me
because i was trying to hold it back
waiting to get some validation
there gun would use athlete testimonials
to help sell those early products to
both other athletes and anyone else who
believed it could help
and made headlines when during the 2017
nba finals kyrie irving was spotted
using one on the sidelines
but with attention came many companies
looking to compete in the space
today a simple amazon search can reveal
the multitude of devices on the market
some at a tenth of the price of current
theraguns
[Music]
in 2020 theragun would rebrand to
therabody and the company would expand
into other recovery products continuing
to take equipment that originated in
training rooms and bringing them to the
general population
it's also opening locations like this
called reset
the idea for reset
came from us seeing these things behind
doors and not allowing the general
population to experience it we couldn't
like ignore it this room
is our theragun and stretch room
so
if you were here today i would take
these two
and i would treat your body at the same
time yes it's called a double gun sweep
the location allows you to choose from a
menu of sorts for recovery allowing you
to experience both thera-body products
used by their staff
but also products you typically wouldn't
see outside of elite training rooms
things like a red light table hyperbaric
chambers and a cryo chamber
[Music]
i'm gonna open this just to give you the
effect of it
oh
lordy lordy yeah
it's set for 2 minutes and 30 seconds
it's not that long
are you gonna try this now i'm not one
to back down from a challenge so i put
on some protective equipment for my
hands and feet and stood inside the
chamber at negative 141 degrees
fahrenheit
while the jonas brothers blasted in my
headphones to help keep my mind from
freezing for the two and a half minutes
i couldn't help but wonder is all of
this technology aimed at recovering our
bodies
worth this
little frost on your eyelashes
athletes should be prioritizing recovery
in the same way that they prioritize
training it's that important this is
christy ashwanden a journalist and
author of the book good2go where she
wrote about the science of recovery
i read hundreds probably close to a
thousand scientific research articles
while i was working on the book looking
at all sorts of these things and i can
just say having done that and having
interviewed hundreds of researchers that
there's not a lot of evidence that this
stuff does much
professional sports teams spend millions
if not billions of dollars each year in
various sports science fields
players themselves also invest heavily
on their own health lebron james
reportedly spends about 1.5 million
dollars on his body every year
i want this stuff to work i'll tell you
what you know i was willing to try
anything while i was working on this
book i tried almost all of these major
recovery techniques that are being
marketed now for recovery but what i
found is that most of them if they made
a difference the difference was very
marginal
including unfortunately for me
cryotherapy
in her book christy points to research
that couldn't establish any evidence of
recovery benefits in whole body
cryotherapy
the fda would also put out a consumer
warning about the lack of evidence for
the treatment and warned of potential
risks
you want to see it
are you sure you want to see it
frostbite is reportedly to blame for
sidelining antonio brown he reportedly
went to france last month to undergo
cryotherapy a source says he didn't wear
the proper footwear and as a result his
feet were frostbitten
despite this elite teams around the
world continue to use cryotherapy in
2021 the dallas cowboys even announced
an official cryo partner
there's really good evidence for some
things that really do help recovery it's
sleep it's stress reduction these are
things that you know are very hard to
commercialize very hard to monetize
what we're seeing now though is sports
leagues you know everyone wants to keep
up with everyone else and when you see
your competition using this new device
you think well we have to do that too
because what if it works and so it's not
even about the science necessarily it's
about the culture of this is what
everyone's doing now so we better be
doing it when it comes to devices like
massage guns the amount of research is
still relatively small
some studies of recovery technology
products have concluded they show
beneficial effects
but while the industry has touted such
findings the studies generally use small
samples and often themselves call for
the need for more research
some are also not peer reviewed
the quality of the the science in a lot
of fields of sports science is pretty
low and this is not to slam researchers
it's that these studies are really hard
to conduct it's difficult particularly
if you're looking at elite athletes i
mean you tell me how you're going to do
a study where you take elite athletes
and you ask them to change something so
that you can study it they're not going
to do that most of these studies are
very small and so the results that they
get aren't very reliable there's a lot
of uncertainty in them so i think we
just have to be very careful now this is
changing i think there's a growing
recognition now that there needs to be
more rigor applied to these sorts of
studies it's not an easy nut to crack
that's hard to get bigger sample sizes
for some of these studies
[Music]
conclusive scientific research takes
time and with new devices coming out
every year and eager athletes willing to
try
it may be a while before we could
definitively understand what products
are actually doing to your body
but it's important to know that while
there may not be conclusive scientific
evidence of physiological gains from
recovery devices that doesn't
necessarily mean they aren't effective
especially when it comes to the mind i
don't want to be too dismissive of this
stuff you know some of these massage
tools feel really good and that's worth
something it really is and if you feel
better using these massage tools i say
go for it the placebo effect is often
sort of dismissed as something that's no
good but i think that it's something
that we can in some cases really you
know
harness for good
i wanted to come to a place where these
types of devices were being used here at
the university of pittsburgh athletic
trainers work to take care of the
student athletes holistically you'll see
many of the same devices here that are
used by the staff but as they explain
they are working not just to treat
students bodies but their minds as well
there's
more than one thing that we do not a lot
but there are some things that we do
that
are for the placebo effect to make
someone think we're doing something you
know there's something to be said for
rest this is jennifer brown the senior
associate athletic director for sports
medicine at the university of pittsburgh
and she oversees all areas of
performance including nutrition strength
and conditioning as well as mental
health rest in recovery is so important
and the more we do this the more we
realize the importance of those
athletes they're competitive they want
to know what they do to get better some
of them think it's go go go go well we
know if you keep going and keep going no
matter who you are at some point in time
something's gonna break and do you think
that's where some of that
recovery placebo tech can come in where
you're trying to get them to understand
that they need to rest so it's like
let's bring this thing in that makes
them think that that's what's happening
like they're still doing something but
it's actually just helping them rest a
little bit absolutely there's a lot of
times where we're like hey do this
it's for nothing else than for ha to
have them sit down they don't like the
concept of doing nothing and completely
resting and so what can we do that seems
like something and that is helping them
in some way but isn't too much or too
taxing i would say the vast majority of
these products that target recovery are
really just giving athletes something to
do while they wait for their bodies to
recover on their own naturally yeah that
happens whether you use these devices or
not
but as jennifer explains that time isn't
just useful for their body health the
mental side of the game is something
companies like hyper ice are already
interested in in 2021 hyper ice bought
the mental wellness company core
lebron has also gotten in the game and
partnered with com to create content
meant to promote mental fitness
you know when i was growing up or you
know some of our coaches we talked about
mental health had a stigma to it you had
a mental illness do we really talk about
that well that has changed we certainly
have people that are mental health
therapists and social workers counselors
psychiatrists psychologists that that's
their training but you know as athletic
trainers or you know even coaches or our
you know academic advisors we're all
talking to students and it's just you
know caring about them making sure we
are genuine making sure we're you know
asking people how are you how are you
and listening not just passing in the
hallway but like actually listening to
what they say not judging them
everybody's perception is different but
to each individual what they perceive is
what matters to them
what might work for one player mentally
could be different for another and the
same is true when it comes to recovery
technology it's all about making sure
they feel good
while our most popular games have been
played nearly the same way for decades
everyone from coaches to players to
owners to your average enthusiast is
always looking for the next competitive
edge and technology will always be there
to provide at least the chance for the
next big advantage